wow champagne and oysters you really
shouldn't have guys it's a special night
so when did you guys meet five years ago
we first met five years ago
but we don't count it because i was
dating a speed boat model at the time
and i was dating a super handsome
comptroller of a major u.s city anyways
about a year ago we bumped into each
other at a bar and
we haven't been able to keep our hands
off each other since
so how did you know she was the one oh
i'd love to answer that um
you know
just whenever i look at her face and the
attached physique and you
uh
he makes me laugh
and you know there's really no one
else's opinion who i care about more
than her so
[Music]
hey seriously we're cool right yeah
totally we're fine okay
gosh you know i'm actually a little bit
hungry i never ended up eating at that
dumb fancy restaurant
know what i'm getting on my way home
yeah you're gonna go to the polish place
and get pierogies potato pancakes and a
cup of hot chocolate
that's exactly what i'm gonna get
i will be having pizza two slices of
meat supreme from tony served display
temperature meat supreme is a million
red flags and eating it cold is just
insane no it's not cold it's display
temperature there's a difference amy no
jake he's looking at us
well this is happening huh
[Music]
nypd we are police colleagues you're
under arrest this is a work event i love
you so much hey jerkos this little [ __ ]
escaped so that ought to teach
did you just mm-hmm and did you see
mm-hmm
to jake and amy to jake
great stuff great stuff so since peralta
altered the cummerbund no one really won
the heist this year is that what
everyone's thinking captain right right
sorry not the time i'm so happy for you
both technically there was no winner
continue hey gina just texted me she
said weird i didn't even realize they
were dating
jk so happy for you [ __ ]
so jake tell us everything did you call
amy stat first i actually did mr
santiago i'm calling to inform you that
i plan to ask your daughter to marry me
but since it's 2017 i am not asking for
your permission as she is not your
property nor would she be mine if she
chooses to say yes she's a strong
independent woman and she don't need no
man that being said i truly hope she
says yes but it's her decision so just
back off oh that was perfect what did he
say i have no idea i left a voicemail
i'm terrified of him
not to talk out of turn but i think i
get credit for giving jake the idea to
propose
how's that remember a day in the kitchen
so what i'm saying is vanilla yogurt is
good but pair it with a blueberry yogurt
and both of them taste even better get
it
yes i did not get it but speaking of
yogurt you've eaten six gps devices this
week you should definitely see a doctor
what um look sarge i think everyone
knows that i planted the idea in jake's
head eight years ago
oh hi i'm starting today detective
santiago oh detective peralta welcome
aboard
i'm hearing wedding bells
hi detective boyle it actually really
slowed things down it took like four
years for me to forget that memory yeah
i'm my own worst enemy look no one gave
me the idea i decided to ask amy to
marry me all on my own on april 28th
there's a typo in this crossword puzzle
santiago your test result from the
sergeant's exam has arrived
everybody make room amy needs adequate
space to do her signature dork dance i
don't know if there's gonna be a dork
dance oh look how small that envelope is
that's not a big good news envelope
that's a little bad news envelope what
that's nuts sarge tell her envelope size
doesn't matter if i'm being honest i got
a much bigger envelope oh god unhelpful
terry very unhelpful mine was bigger too
okay i just won't ever open it that way
i'll never get rejected fine i'll open
it no no no
do it harder i opened it
you passed oh oh my god i'm gonna be a
surgeon you're gonna be a sergeant yes
oh no it's happening
yeah that's my future wife
so i believe you prepared your own vows
yes i
was going to do an adam's family themed
wrap but my beatboxer isn't here that's
the only reason it's not happening so
ames
today has been a crazy day
but
i shouldn't be surprised
because we've had a lot of crazy days
there was our first date
our first kiss
the first time you told me you loved me
and the day you told me you would marry
me
also yesterday
and the day before that and the day
before that
because every single day that i get to
be with someone as amazing as you is
crazy to me
i love you
and i'm worried about dancing in front
of our friends
the end
okay well
i've been planning this wedding for the
last six months and if you told me
yesterday everything that was gonna go
wrong
i would have had a panic attack that
sent me into the er
but i'm here
and i've never been happier
life is unpredictable
not everything's in our control but as
long as you're with the right people you
can handle anything
and you jake peralta
are the right person for me
but i do have some bad news
there is a bomb at this wedding as well
what your butt
your butt is the bomb there will be no
survivors
i love you so much you're my dream girl
i love you too
i can't wait to spend the rest of my
life with you
ring bearer please bring the rings but i
thought cheddar was sick oh my god
you got the robot there's a robot at my
wedding yeah i felt bad about how
everything went down today so i offered
to help oh that's nice also are you guys
doing the thing where someone gets to
object to this union or is that later
not doing that you've outsmarted me
congratulations okay moving on
do you amy santiago take jake peralta to
be your husband
i do
and do you jake peralta take amy
santiago to be your wife
i absolutely do
[Music]
by the power vested in me by the state
of new york i'd like to announce that
your honeymoon vacation request status
has officially been moved from pending
to approved
you're married you may kiss the bride
[Applause]
sam i'm here oh jake i can't believe i
made it i'm going to see the birth of my
oh we're on page 53. babe we're on page
53. dino i rode a horse
well
we did it ames
we made the world's hottest baby
say cute jake no this kid is liquid fire
crazy to think in just 17 short years
he's gonna be six foot seven in the
number one draft pick for the knicks hmm
and then he's gonna pass up that
opportunity to pursue his true passion
library sciences well the important
thing is we'll support him no matter
what even if he's a huge huge nerd oh
especially then
are we gonna be okay at this
i mean this entire day felt like a
warning from the universe i almost
missed the birth we had our baby at the
precinct a firefighter touched our child
we washed him off yeah but i'll always
know babe we talked about this
everyone balances working kids yeah but
everyone's not a cop true but
when our son wants to hear about the day
he was born
we get to tell him that his dad helped a
bunch of people and foiled a bank
robbery
i guess that is kind of cool
and his mom managed a city-wide
emergency while actually giving birth
i'm proud for her son to have you as a
dad
me too
for you to be the mom i was just
agreeing with the nice thing you said
about me i love you
you